it shall be noted joe got covered
almost a rhyme
this morning the white house revealed
the prez has covered and is experiencing
mild symptoms including chills sniffles
and not knowing who he is
[Applause]
in other words nothing's changed
white house press secretary karine
jean-pierre said for now he'll work in
isolation which should be easy
considering that's how he spent his
campaign biden should recover from covet
but with friends like these his
re-election plans are clearly doa
president biden held a controversial
meeting with the crown prince of saudi
arabia
yeah
biden said that wasn't a fist bump that
was me trying to punch him as hard as i
could
maybe that's not a fist bump maybe it's
79 that's as hard as joke and punch
throw them dukes out muhammad bin
jackman stop asking him about the fist
bump ask him about the looming recession
no actually just asked me about the
first bomb meanwhile i read that dr
fauci said that he plans to retire by
the end of president biden's term
and then everyone turned to biden like
is there anything you'd like to announce
two
so better late than never guys even
though those jokes are as toothless as
old joe himself
and so his media enablers are fleeing
like rats from the titanic and he should
know he was on board that disaster too
meanwhile thursday officials unveiled
the president's safer american plan
america plan or sap
and it's basically a massive refunding
of the police yep the party that was all
about defunding now wants to spend 37
billion to quote support law enforcement
and crime prevention it's biden's
boldest move on crime since he paid for
hunter's [ __ ]
the proposed plan would uh would help
hire and train an additional hundred
thousand cops good invest three billion
to clear court backlogs and another five
billion in community violence
intervention programs also included
aoc's provision for thousands of
invisible handcuffs
yes
so the dems
the dams are now pretending to be pro
cop when they're just trying to repair
what they destroyed when they were
anti-cop
or maybe they're just trying to help
corey bush save money on private
security
but really they're doing it to save
their own asses imagine having to deal
with someone who destroys things so they
can fix them
hey danny cool sunglasses can i see yeah
sure phil
wow
you know these are they're broken
ruined them hey let's not play the blame
game
you know i can fix these if you like
you're the one that just broke them you
know i'm all about results let me just
see if i can't
hey there you go
you're welcome
i guess
that uh those two pairs of sunglasses
for the skit came out of our budget
like half our budget yeah it is half our
budget um would you care to comment on
this the breaking news of covid or the
police uh i guess i know it's just all
this
all right no more multiple choices okay
no because i actually what i just i
can't get over like how we're talking
about this new stuff like the whole oil
cancer thing didn't happen yesterday
i can't get over it oh you know what he
said like he said i have cancer yes from
oil on my mom's windshield 70 years ago
i know
skin cancer too yeah
no and they're like no he just meant
like he had some like skin cancer but
i'm like that is not even close to what
he said
like
am i the only one that's still thinking
about this no and it's a it's a maybe
that's why they announced kobe yeah and
then maybe it doesn't even happen
this article i was looking it up and
people like wrote this article like
here's why joe biden said he was
affected by cancer he did not say that
he said i have oil cancer yes
[Laughter]
to me i think it's a really big sign of
how crazy things have gotten when i
looked at twitter for hours last night
about the oil cancer because some people
a lot of people like wait does he have
cancer does he not and some people are
like how crazy it is that the
president's like i have cancer and we're
like what does it mean
and then other people were like
regardless of you know your political
values we have to agree that this cancer
is a serious thing and thoughts and
prayers are by oil cancer i mean
she went with choose your own adventure
no like i know because i just i'm not
willing to move on from the announcement
of oil cancer
and then being gaslit by this
administration that i should not be
having this type of reaction yeah no
it's a fair point and
it's a fair point because if trump had
said anything like that could you
imagine the interpretations i mean i
said anything like that
that is true that is true you okay now
if i ever say i have cancer it'll be
because i do yes we hope that never
happens no it probably will i know the
stats
you really are a dark dark human being
joe ah covet big
you know big fairly big news how do you
think it's going to affect his job i
think at this point it can only improve
his performance oh okay yes i think he
should turn himself over to the virus
like one of those wafts that injects a
parasite into a victim
uh i think that he's going to be a tough
one to bring down i mean he beat the
1918 flu that didn't stop him
as cat mentioned he he kicked cancer in
24 hours
that's unheard of
and
he's got the best people around him
taking care of him comma left him a nice
hot bowl of bat soup hoping to get
better
and i think it's look at the immune
system in that family look at his son
hunter what his
if i bet if you put a condom on hunter
it would inflate like a balloon animal
just from the power in him
so um that's an image joe's gonna be
fine uh the country's in a lot of
trouble but joe's going to be fine
exactly and you know the other thing too
cash is she's so lucky to be married to
a doctor
well she's that's why she got he got
cured so fast
she pumped him full of invermectin and
horse stuff and everything else that was
available and she was like reading it
from one of her books
but uh i'll comment on the police i mean
nobody wants to take it so i'll take it
as a former federal prosecutor why not
right uh i think yeah fun cops it's a
no-brainer the problem is these guys
have been defunding them so much that
they now set up a program that doesn't
do anything it prints money to the
federal government the federal
government can't fund state police
officers that's what state governments
are for so now we have what fake money
and balloons going up in
smoke and it's just it's saying that
you're attacking a problem that you
created by not providing enough i didn't
realize that that like this they can't
it's like so where does the money go so
they have to so okay long story short
you have to apply for this giant grant
so you have to greece kids pay lobbyists
go to doj get on your hands and knees
beg them to uh not investigate hunter
biden and then you get a hundred billion
dollars in return wow that's a total
scam wow i would do that
for that money and i'm not even a i'm
not even whatever cash is i'm
really not sure what he is at this point
and i mean you i mean as a profession
i don't really know it either yeah
that's why you can charge so much
exactly
julie um where do you where what would
you like you you are you are the face of
news here well that's why i think i
should address the news we're not
talking about jill biden yeah i mean so
she uh tested negative which good for
her right okay thank god
i'm not even catholic but
i will say this um as a spouse of a
husband who formerly had coveted i do
have some advice for her
run like hell because while this covet
variant is like a cold for us females it
is an insufferable man flu oh so case in
point in april i had a trip planned for
miami and the morning of our flight
guess what the husband you know tested
for kofid and he was positive so what
did i do i be lined it to the airport
and i head out and i think
i think this is a this is an excellent
opportunity for social distancing for
spouses across the country that's what i
say and that was way back in april i am
due for a new vacation and i am sensing
monkey monkey monkey pucks monkey pops
next monkey pox all right
i also think aoc's handcuffs are a safe
sex toy
that's funny oh cash
[Laughter]
thank god you're not in government
[Laughter]
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else